welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is an explanation of the
ending of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
and how James Gunn brought to conclusion
his Guardian Saga in the MCU and the
musicians whose royalties he skyrocketed
by putting them in the soundtrack I know
it's really early but a lot of you are
starting to see this movie as of today
and I am here right now to just clear up
any questions you might have coming out
of this film and point to some details
and full circle callbacks you might have
missed now we'll talk about the
post-credits scenes a bit in this video
but really I'm gonna dig into them more
in a separate video here I'm just going
to cover how this movie in general wraps
everything up and some unanswered
questions also my live breakdown and Q a
of this movie will be on the Deep dive
Channel tomorrow at noon Eastern come
join me for that and bring all your
questions and you can support us by
grabbing some of our Guardians inspired
shirts at nerd riot.shop okay spoilers
ahead obviously so Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 reveals that rocket was a
test subject created by the high
evolutionary Herbert Wyndham numbered
89p13 part of the 89 batch of broken
toys that also included Lila thiefs and
floor Rock it was the only one of
windham's Creations capable of original
thought and invented problem solving
which really frustrated Windham who had
planned to populate his new world's
counter Earth not with rocket and his
friends but with other animalistic
hybrids who could be rapidly evolved
into humanoids without violent outbursts
though life found a way and general
human dickishness found a way rocket
tried to free Lila and the others giving
her a wonderful hug but Herbert kills
the other three and Rocket scratches the
hell out of his face and escapes ever
since 89 p13 was windham's 24601 Pursuit
when you need more from Marvel you need
Marvel future fight from netmarble
Marvel future fight is one of the top
Marvel mobile games on the planet an
action RPG where you can pit over 250
Marvel characters against one another
beyond the dizzying array of characters
to choose from there are also 420
different uniforms and outfits from
across the MCU including brand new
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 outfits
starting May 3rd you'll be able to play
a Star-Lord rocket or mantis wearing
their Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
outfits it looks like they stepped right
out of the screen into your phone in
addition Star-Lord will have a new tier
4 advancement rocket will have a new
tier 3 advancement and mantis will have
a new uniform and Awakening skill now if
you've never played Marvel future fight
before now is the perfect time to start
Marvel future fight has been up and
running for eight years now providing
continuous monthly updates so there's
always something new to do Marvel future
fight is available on Android and iOS to
get started just click the link in the
description or head to your App Store
and search Marvel future fight today we
also learned that it was Windham who
created the genetically perfect
Sovereign Aisha and her new baby boy
Adam Warlock from Volume 2 and Adam in
an opening attack in the film severely
wounds rocket and the Guardians are
unable to heal rock it without
triggering a kill switch so the
Guardians have to go to orgo court for
Rockets parts manual and then from there
go find windham's recorder Theo on
counter Earth tackling him out of
Windham ship but leaving nebula track
semantis on Windows ship as it leaves
counter Earth behind to explode Wyndham
ship is kind of a Noah's Arc of animal
test subjects larger animal warriors
with cybernetic parts and caged children
in Seal wigs spread with efficient
metabolisms and happiness levels whom
Drax Just Hits it off with because
remember he had a daughter he's a good
daddy so these three run into some
obelisks suggesting these were also
Creations by Herbert Wyndham but mantis
is able to tame them and all the
Guardians come back together on the ship
striking the ship with the mobilized
skull of nowhere they fight through
windham's Warriors in a sick hallway
fight sent to the Beastie Boys No Sleep
till Brooklyn and Rocket returns to his
old cage sadly looking inside at the
other young raccoons that are in there
still and he reads the inside label the
cage to confirm that he is indeed a
North American raccoon Windham tries to
kill him but the Guardians gang up on
Windham including Gamora who delivers on
Peter Quill's recurring promise in this
movie that it would be a face off and
peels off windham's face and reminding
us a lot of Marvel's last evil eugenesis
Red Skull we see the Bloody Face rocket
left Windham with and he gasps I just
wanted to make things perfect and Rocket
responds he didn't want to make things
perfect he just hated things the way
they uh and Rocket refuses to kill him
saying I'm a freaking Guardian of the
Galaxy the Guardians evacuate all life
forms off Wyndham ship to Nowhere kids
and the animals including this little
weirdo named lamb shank voiced by James
Gunn it sounds like
I was screaming at something scary
behind you not you you look really cool
thanks
but Peter has to run back for his Zune
and this falling apart ship's airlock
link with nowhere gets severed so Peter
has to space jump he gets stuck everyone
cries thinking he's gonna die as his
face floats up and Adam Warlock
recreates Michelangelo's creation of
Adam to rescue Peter and fly him back
Gamora looks out over the new arrivals
of nowhere and says she never really
figured out with Peter in this movie
since she was for another timeline with
no history with him she turns to leave
with the ravagers but stops to tell
Peter I bet we were fun and Peter
responds like you wouldn't believe then
Peter tells the other Guardians he's
leaving as does mantis Drax wants to go
with mantis but nebulous says she needs
tracks to look after these kids saying
you weren't born to be a destroyer you
were born to be a dad Peter names rocket
the new captain of the Guardians they
salute Rocket and Groot for the first
time saying words other than I am we are
or Groot for the first time says I love
you guys rocket pulls out the Zune which
has a page torn from Peter's Alf comic
with a message written from yandu saying
I went back and got this for repeat
rocket Scrolls to the 2000s playlist and
plays Florence and the sheens the dog
days are over and as this plays over the
speakers are nowhere it becomes a huge
dance party rocket and Groot dance
together Drax waves goodbye to mantis
who lives with the obelisks and Drax who
has always claimed to be a non-dancer
joins the Sea of wig kids in the dance
circle Peter returns to his old
neighborhood in Missouri after mantis
reminded him in this movie that he had
family back on Earth that his
grandfather lost both his daughter and
his grandson on that day in 1988 Peter
asks for Jason quill establishing that
his middle name that we saw in the
xandar booking screen in the 2014 film
Jason comes from his grandpa in the
two-man hug we end the film back on
nowhere Cosmo house nebulous screams
Groot Roars and rocket after denying
being a raccoon throughout all these
films and finally realizing that he
actually is one Embraces his inner
animal and lets loose a howl now the
post-credits scenes show the new
Guardians lineup with the young phyla
you know who she is in the post credit
scene video as well as a massive Alpha
group listening to red bones come and
get your love an early song from the
2014 film and the second scene showing
Peter eating breakfast with Grandpa
Jason talking about helping someone mow
the grass but that her son should help
and Jason says don't even get me started
dishing somewhere Retirement Village
Goss it sounds like but one thing we
need to address is the high evolutionary
in his mysterious backstory I mentioned
the visual parallel with Johann Schmidt
Red Skull but there is a philosophical
similarity between them when it comes to
their desire to perfect humanity and
perfect earth based on the principles of
eugenics and Friedrich Nietzsche's
uberman or the superior man something
that influenced the Nazis and which
Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster co-opted to
create Superman and American superhero
comics to combat Nazi propaganda from
the 1930s which is how we also got
Captain America and all of Marvel Comics
as well remember there was a flashback
where rocket told Windham I can't and
Windham corrected [__] using a proper
British accent also sounding like a
horrible insult but also a homophone for
Kant as in Emmanuel Kant another German
philosopher who founded the ethical
principle that an action can only be
moral if Aid is motivated by a sense of
Duty and B its Maxim may be rationally
wielding Universal objective law Wyndham
was definitely inspired by the culture
and philosophy that he found on Earth he
listened to Earthly Gregory
aligned himself with Henry IV as he
played these scenes heavy lies the head
that wears the crown and in this scene
there's an interesting exchange with
Peter Quill your friend once took
advantage
I learned my lessons
I aimed some small parts of my mental
capacity back in my own Direction and
now gravity itself serves my whims you
must find counter Earth familiar counter
Earth I visited your planet many years
ago Earth hasn't been my planet in a
long time you know people had
wonderful spirit the art and music and
literature were some of the finests in
the universe
Earth would be a fabulous place for it
not for the ignorance and bigotry okay
now in the comics Herbert Wyndham was an
early 20th century scientist and set up
a base on wounded Gore Mountain that we
saw in the MCU and Multiverse Madness
but in the comics mundugor Mountain was
where he had a base where his creation
Bova nurse Pietro and Wanda maximoff now
in the MCU Herbert Windham founded
orgocorp a company that creates
cybernetic parts for civilizations
across the Galaxy and he's seen as a god
figure who created races like the any
men and The Sovereign and it was implied
that he may have created and strayed
past counter Earths the way he viewed
this one is so disposable and what's
scariest about all this is Wyndham might
still be alive and his influence lives
on in an Empire of creation's bread
according to his awful philosophy that
Cosmic caste system Remains the most
disturbing part of this film not just
the violent stored animals that are
triggering some audiences but beneath
all that a nefarious tolerance from
everyone else in the cosmic MCU of a
wannabe God who could get away with this
speciesist murder and genocide for so
long let's just hope this guy never
teams up with Red Skull another Marvel
villain who is still out there face
somewhere hey a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and you
can support us for grabbing some merch
at nerdright.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]